As we saw the supreme court in 1972 says
the death penalty is unconstitutional
and Furman versus Georgia.
But the court's decision is a mess.
We have five justices in the majority,
all finding it unconstitutional
for different reasons.
Some of them saying it's unconstitutional
because the way it has been used up
until the time and four in the dissent
saying it's up to the legislature's
basically.
And so what happens after
Fermin is decided in 1973,
Georgia passes a new death penalty
statute signed into law by then governor
Jimmy Carter in March of
1973 and by May of 1973,
Georgia's carrying out
death penalty trials.
Once again,
uh,
the same thing right
promptly after Fermin,
Texas passes a new a
death penalty statute.
And so do 35 states and just
a very short period of time,
four years,
a number of states have responded to the
firm and decision by passing new death
penalty statutes,
which they think are designed to deal
with the main problem that the court
identified in Ferman arbitrariness.
So two ways to do this.
One,
tell the jury how to make its decision
that is guide the discretion of the jury.
Or secondly,
what Justice Burger warrant about
in his dissenting opinion in Fermin,
which is make the duck putting mandatory,
take any discretion out of the process,
uh,
and say you commit a certain crime,
you commit a please,
you kill a police officer and the
punishment is going to be the death.
Polly.
Uh,
so North Carolina,
Louisiana passed the
mandatory statutes there.
Case come their cases come
before the court in 1976.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the court grants review of the Georgia,
Florida,
and Texas statutes.
And so let's look at what each state did
in response to Fermin and then how the
court in deciding these five cases,
Greg versus Georgia out of Georgia profit,
uh,
versus Florida out of Florida and,
and so forth,
jerk versus Texas,
uh,
Woodson versus in North Carolina
a and Roberts versus Louisiana.
Uh,
how the court makes the determination
of what's constitutional and what's not.
Let's first look at what Georgia did.
What every state did was
provide for a bifurcated trial.
This,
we had seen in mcgautha,
uh,
with California having one trial on
guilt or innocence and another trial on
penalty.
The idea being you're
not compromised in the,
in a unitary trial,
uh,
by having to decide,
am I going to defend the case on guilt
or innocence or am I going to put
evidence before the jury that's of
sports a sentence less than death.
Now there are two different inquiries.
First determine if the person guilty,
then go to a second sentencing phase,
which will be focused just on sentencing.
Uh,
and then aggravating circumstances.
Georgia adopts 10,
and it's Duff Poly Statute,
uh,
one,
whether the murder is committed
in the course of another felony.
This is basically felony murder,
uh,
that the court is saying a is
eligible for the death polling.
Uh,
and as you see rape,
armed robbery,
kidnapping,
aggravated battery,
burglary,
arson.
The question is,
are we finding a way to narrow
the application of the death?
Polly,
and one of the controversial questions
on this is with regard to these felony
murder statutes,
because almost all murders occur
in the course of another crime.
Uh,
the classic being of course,
the holdup of a convenient store,
uh,
in which someone is shot and killed a,
those are the cases are all
eligible for the death polling.
Most of them will not be
prosecuted as death pony cases,
but they can be.
So the question becomes,
does this eliminate the arbitrary is
that we saw in Ferman or is this enough
guidance for the jury,
uh,
that we don't have that arbitrators?
Uh,
another factor,
the prior record,
uh,
of the,
defendant,
does this person have a prior
conviction for capital felony?
If so,
that is a reason to give the person a,
the death pony,
uh,
whether the a person's
actions and committing the
crime created a great risk of
death to more than one person,
uh,
another,
whether it was for money or any other
thing of monetary value we've covered
here,
but an awful lot of the kinds
of crimes that take place,
uh,
when life is lost.
Uh,
but all of these are at least,
uh,
you have objective factors to consider.
Is there a robbery?
Uh,
is there a prior capital felony?
was there a great risk of death,
but then the court,
then the state legislature
adopts the catchall aggravating,
which really is more descriptive
than it is anything else.
Was the murderer outrageously
and wantonly vile,
horrible and inhuman.
I suppose every murder
is outrageously wantonly,
vile,
horrible,
inhuman.
But the legislature tacks onto that
and that didn't involve torture.
We know what torture is.
That's a crime.
And juries can figure that out.
Uh,
depravity of mind on the part
of the defendant in creating a,
in committing the crime,
uh,
which is,
hard to fathom or notice any one of these,
an aggravated battery to the victim.
We'll see some other
states adopt a catchall,
a aggravating factors,
which are much more vague
than the Georgia one.
Uh,
but here,
if a prosecutor finds that the death pony
doesn't fit under any of these others,
then it can be,
uh,
perhaps fit under the
outrageously Wanli vile,
horrible,
and inhuman aggravating circumstance.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
the state,
provides.
There must be at least one
aggravating factor established,
no aggravating factor established.
That's the end of the process.
Uh,
the jury returns a verdict of,
of life imprisonment.
The jury can consider anything
as a mitigating circumstance.
We'll see a Florida statute,
which gives the jury a list of
mitigating circumstances but not Georgia.
Georgia says,
once an aggravating factors
has been established,
the jury can consider
anything else in aggravation.
So that's wide open.
And then the jury can consider
any mitigating factor.
And we'll talk more
about mitigating factors,
but basically mercy evoking reasons for
imposing a sentence less than death.
Uh,
anything about the life and background
of the person may be mitigating
circumstances of the crime.
Uh,
why it was committed or some
aspect of the way it was committed.
Uh,
perhaps the defendant had a lesser
role of being one of several people who
committed a crime.
Or maybe it's something about,
uh,
the defendant himself,
that that is the mitigating
factor or factors.
Um,
but once an aggravating
factor is found in Georgia,
the jury has complete discretion,
finds one aggravating factor,
and then it can give death or life.
It can give life in prison even
if it finds no mitigating factors.
Uh,
but once it has that information
before it a complete discretion,
jury must be unanimous.
This is not going to be
the law in every state,
but in Georgia,
the jury must be unanimous.
Uh,
if it can't reach a verdict
than it's a life sentence,
uh,
imposed.
Uh,
but the jury's recommendation is binding,
uh,
on the judge.
Uh,
in other words,
the jury sentences,
this is not,
we're going to look at some
judge sentencing statutes,
uh,
but this statute provides
for jury sentencing.
So in order for the prosecution
to get the death penalty,
uh,
it has to convince all 12 members of
the jury that there's at least one
statutory aggravating circumstance,
uh,
and that the death penalty is appropriate
for the crime considering both the
facts of the crime and the background and
circumstances of the person facing the
death.
Pollock,
Georgia also provides a
for an automatic appeal,
uh,
to the Georgia Supreme Court,
where that court is to decide whether
the death penalty is imposed under the
influence of passion,
prejudice,
or any other arbitrary factor,
uh,
whether the evidence supports
the aggravating circumstance,
uh,
and whether the sentence is
excessive or disproportionate.
The idea being that the Georgia Supreme
Court will look at all the death
sentences imposed in the state of Georgia
and make a determination of whether a,
there's some that really compared
to other cases should not be a death
sentences.
Now,
the court only looks at this in 1976
as to whether the statute satisfies the
constitution.
Uh,
in practice,
none of these things really happen.
Uh,
the Georgia Supreme Court just pastes a
boilerplate paragraph in his decisions
saying that it finds the duff plenty
was not imposed under the influence of
passion,
prejudice,
or an arbitrary factor that evidence
supports the aggravating circumstance and
then a tax on some other decisions in
an appendix a where it says the death
penalty was imposed in these cases.
So it's not disproportionate,
uh,
in this case.
So,
uh,
this has been a rather hollow promise,
but the Supreme Court is going to say
proportionality review is not required.
Uh,
anyway.
Um,
so,
uh,
Florida provides for a bifurcated
trial just like Georgia.
Uh,
again,
a list of aggravating circumstances.
It's not a whole lot different
than what we saw prior conviction.
This we saw in Georgia have a felony,
uh,
or in prison and parole,
same one we saw in Georgia.
Great risk of death.
Uh,
too many people,
uh,
in the Commission of another felony.
Here again,
felony murder cases,
uh,
are all going to be eligible
for the death penalty.
So if it's a murder in the commission
of a robbery and kidnapping,
a sexual battery,
uh,
arson,
those cases are going to be
eligible for the death penalty.
Uh,
and then here's the Catchall,
uh,
was the murder especially heinous,
atrocious or cruel?
Virtually every murder is heinous,
atrocious and cruel.
So the question's going to come up.
Does this really give the
jury any principle basis
for deciding whether or not
to impose the death penalty?
Uh,
the court,
the statute also provided a,
that if the murder is committed in a cold,
calculated and premeditated manner,
again,
these are more descriptive as opposed to
a definitions of what might make a case
aggravated enough,
uh,
for the death penalty to be imposed.
But those questions are
going to come later.
The Supreme Court for now,
and of course I have not given you
with regard either Georgia or Florida,
all of the aggravating circumstances,
but if given me the ones that
tend to be used the most often,
uh,
and,
and apply to the most cases,
and of course more than anything else,
is going to be the felony murder,
a murder in the commission of
a robbery or some other crime.
Now far,
it also provides for
mitigating circumstances,
but unlike Georgia,
which just says the jury can consider
anything else once it finds an aggravating
factor to consider anything else,
uh,
in mitigation of Florida actually
provides a list for the jury,
uh,
of the mitigating factors.
No significant history of
prior criminal activity,
uh,
extreme emotional distress,
that the person committed the crime.
Uh,
you can imagine a
domestic disturbance and,
uh,
the wife has been beaten by her husband
and she goes out and shoots him and
could argue that there's extreme mental
or emotional disturbance cause where
that cases Algebra for the death penalty,
or not a threshold question,
but a prosecutor could say it was heinous,
atrocious and cruel.
Uh,
the victim was a participant almost
never is the victim of participant or a
consented to a murder.
Uh,
so this one doesn't really apply a very
much a relatively minor participation.
Uh,
as I talked about a moment ago,
one of the mitigating factors
that may arise in a case,
particularly when several
people commit a crime together,
uh,
is whether the,
any one of those people was sort of the,
you know,
the lookout person or was
less involved in the crime,
uh,
than some of the others.
Uh,
extreme duress duress is
not a defense to murder,
but extreme duress.
Somebody who,
for example,
is in a gang and put under a lot of
pressure to commit a crime as part of an
initiation or a for whatever reason
that could be a mitigating factor.
Now,
none of these mitigating factors
cancel out the death pony.
They're just factors that the jury must
consider in deciding whether or not to
impose the death pony.
Uh,
and finally,
uh,
the capacity of the
defendant to appreciate,
uh,
or conform,
his behavior to the
requirements of the law.
Uh,
if a defendant has no ability to conform
his behavior to the requirements of the
law,
that's an insanity defense.
Uh,
what the legislature in
Florida is provided for here
is to say a person may not
be so lacking in capacity to
meet the insanity defense,
but their capacity was impaired,
their mental thinking,
uh,
their mental abilities were,
were impaired.
And so that's something that
we will take into account,
uh,
sort of like,
emotional disturbance,
uh,
that that may be a reason,
that the jury can consider.
Again,
these just go into the mix,
the aggravating and mitigating
circumstances as to whether or not,
uh,
death is going to be imposed.
Uh,
in Florida,
uh,
jury ways,
the aggravating and mitigating factors,
the question it asks is,
are there sufficient
mitigating circumstances,
uh,
which outweigh the aggravating.
So unlike Georgia,
which has complete wide open discretion,
once the jury finds an aggravating
circumstance in Florida,
the jury ways,
if it's possible,
is the question that's
worthy of discussion.
But we won't take time for that right now.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the jury theoretically ways the mitigation
against the aggravation and comes out
with a sentence.
Uh,
and then here's another difference.
The recommends punishment by a majority
vote no requirement of unanimity as in
Georgia,
which says you have to have all 12 jurors,
a great in Florida.
It can be seven to five.
Uh,
of course,
what one consequence of that,
uh,
is the kind of deliberations you have.
If you have a requirement of unanimity,
it means everybody has equal power.
You sit down in that jury room,
everybody's got to listen to everybody
else as in the play and movie.
12 angry men,
uh,
until if thrashed it out
and decided what to do.
And so that Ha,
there has to be that interaction.
Florida basically the jury,
although they're totally deliberate,
can go in and take a vote and if it's
seven to five for life or seven to five
for death or whatever it may be a,
they can make their recommendation.
But notice this,
the judge can override
the decision of the jury.
So the jury may come back with life in
prison and the judge may give the death
pony or vice versa.
The jury may come back with death.
Uh,
and the judge may impose,
uh,
life imprisonment.
In fact,
almost all the overrides in Florida and
in other states have been life sentences
by juries which are
overwritten to DeCinces.
Florida ultimately adopted a standard,
uh,
which made it very difficult,
for judges to overwrite jury.
So in Florida,
although there were a lot of overrides
and that time after 1976 when this case
was decided,
uh,
since that time,
there have been fewer
and fewer overrides and,
and virtually none today,
uh,
in Florida.
On the other hand,
Alabama also has a judge override a
really the main state using judge override
today and in Alabama,
20% of the people on death row are
people who receive life sentences from
Alabama juries,
but they were sentenced to
death by judges who overrode,
uh,
the,
the jury.
And of course far it also provides for
automatic review by the State Supreme
Court.
We're going to see this in every state,
whether the defendant asked for it or not,
whether they follow a
notice of appeal or not,
the case is going to
go just as in Georgia.
The case is going to go to the state
Supreme Court and that court is going to
decide,
uh,
review the case and make a decision about
both the legal errors in the case and
maybe some questions about the
appropriateness of the death polling.
Well,
let's go to the great state of Texas,
which has a completely different,
uh,
way of defining which cases are
going to be death poly cases.
First of all,
Texas defines the crime,
uh,
of capital murder as one that's going
to be decided at the guilt phase.
In other words,
there's a crime that if you're
convicted of capital murder,
then your case goes to the penalty phase.
Uh,
we see the same sorts of things,
um,
as,
uh,
making one eligible for capital murder,
a murder of a police,
uh,
or,
or fire person here again,
felony murder,
murder during a kidnapping,
burglary,
robbery,
rape,
arson,
any murder in the commission of another
crime is going to be eligible for the
death penalty.
Murder for a renumeration,
uh,
is as well murder in
the course of an escape.
Uh,
and finally,
a prisoner who kills the prison employee.
Notice what's missing in Texas.
No catchall,
no catchall heinous,
atrocious and cruel or anything like that.
It's pretty well defined,
uh,
in terms of what a person has to do in
order to be eligible for the death pony
in Texas,
the unique part of the Texas statute,
that's part of it,
but a number of states now have capital
murder statutes where at the guilt
phase,
at the same time,
the jury's deciding guilt or innocence.
It's deciding whether the person
is guilty of something plus murder.
In other words,
an aggravating factor that's basically
Texas moves that determination of
aggravating factors into the guilt
phase as opposed to having it,
uh,
as Georgia and Florida
do in the penalty phase.
Uh,
so we get to the,
uh,
penalty phase and the jury
is asked three questions,
uh,
and these are yes,
no questions.
First,
was it deliberate?
Uh,
did the,
uh,
was the conduct deliberate
with a reasonable expectation
that death would occur?
The answer to that question is
almost always going to be yes.
Uh,
because the person has been found guilty
of intentional capital murder at the
guilt phase,
and most likely,
uh,
it's going to be the found
that it was deliberate.
The only question is the
expectation that death would occur,
uh,
that may be an issue in some cases.
Uh,
secondly,
and most importantly,
is the person a future danger to society.
This is a introduced by Texas here and
upheld in 1976 the jury is asked whether
beyond a reasonable doubt,
there is a substantial probability that
the defendant will commit future acts of
violence and be a continuing
threat to society.
This is a highly controversial,
aggravating circumstance.
Uh,
first of all,
what do we mean by
substantial probability?
Uh,
if we say,
if the weatherman tells us there's
a 30% probability of rain tomorrow,
is that a substantial probability a,
or do we have to have a 60% probability,
uh,
or,
or higher?
That's never been decided.
Uh,
and then the question of
can this even be determined?
Can doctors,
psychiatrists,
or psychologists predict
future dangerousness?
Uh,
and can juries make
determinations about it?
Uh,
well in Texas,
they do a,
at the time,
uh,
1970s,
when,
when the death point is
being posted in Texas,
basically a,
in one part of Texas,
uh,
people would be examined
by Dr. James Grigson,
uh,
who would opine that they were a future
danger at the penalty phase of their
trials.
Another part of Texas,
you'd be a doctor Holbrook,
uh,
would be the doctor who had examine a
defendants and provide a opinion that they
were a future danger.
Uh,
and pretty much at the penalty
phase of capital cases,
uh,
in Texas.
That would be the,
the evidence offered by the prosecution
for the death pony because I say it's
not going to be much
question about deliberate.
Uh,
and there's not going to be
much question about this third,
uh,
issue provocation,
whether the defendant's conduct was
unreasonable in response to provocation.
In other words,
did the victim do something which caused
the defendant to commit the crime?
So the,
the first and last generally
are not going to be issues.
So the case is going to come
down to future dangerousness.
And notice this once the jury
answers those three questions.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
The death penalty is imposed.
The judge has no discretion,
uh,
to reject the death.
Money is justice.
Rehnquist says in his dissenting opinion,
uh,
in Jorg versus in the
mandatory death pony cases,
Woodson versus North Carolina
and Roberts versus Louisiana.
He says,
wait a minute,
we've upheld a mandatory death sentence.
The,
the Texas statute is a mandatory statute.
If the jury finds the answers to
three questions in the affirmative,
the death penalty is imposed.
Uh,
this scheme here,
uh,
this statutory approach the Texas took
is the reason that so many people had
been executed in Texas.
Uh,
because,
uh,
if these questions are all answered,
yes,
uh,
there's not the discretion that juries
have in Florida and Georgia to reject the
death penalty and still
impose a life imprisonment.
The jury really,
uh,
is never given that
question under this statute.
Now,
we will learn later in the course that
ultimately the supreme court found some
problems with the statute and the fact
that it didn't allow a certain mitigating
circumstances to be considered.
But in 1976,
the court said,
well,
in answering some of
these other questions,
the jury can take into account
mitigating circumstances.
And so,
uh,
the statutes are going to be,
upheld,
uh,
based upon that,
or the Texas statute was
upheld based upon that.
Uh,
but we'll see,
uh,
the,
there were some problems with the statute.
A supreme court didn't
recognize him for a long time,
and by the time it did,
an awful lot of people had been sentenced
to death and even executed in Texas,
uh,
under this statute,
which was upheld in 1976,
um,
North Carolina,
Louisiana,
as I mentioned before,
adopt mandatory death penalty statutes.
You commit a certain crime.
The death pony is mandatory.
Uh,
this is to prevent arbitrators.
so the court has to decide of these five
death pony statutes that it has before
them.
What's one,
which ones are constitutional,
uh,
in which ones are not.
Uh,
and,
and in these five cases,
uh,
we have some justices who find all the
statutes constitutional chief justice,
Burger justice,
White,
black Rehnquist vote to
uphold both the Florida,
Texas and Georgia statutes.
Uh,
and to hold up all the mandatory statutes.
I just said Brennan and Marshall
would say that the death penalty is
unconstitutional in all cases,
so they would not uphold
any of the statutes.
And so this leaves the decision making
a true a plurality of three justices.
Justice Stewart,
uh,
justice Powell and justice Stevens who's
not come on the court taking justice
Douglas place appointed by President
Gerald Ford and the three of them,
right.
The opinion that joins with,
uh,
Brennan and Marshall to declare the
mandatory death Polly unconstitutional by
very close five to four vote,
uh,
and then join with chief justice Berger
and the others to uphold a the so called
guided discretion statutes.
The statutes that supposedly tell the
jury how it's to make this decision.
The Georgia,
Florida,
and Texas statutes.
So the guided discretion
statutes are upheld seven to two.
The mandatory statutes are a declared
unconstitutional by very close vote of
five to four.
Um,
one could ask,
uh,
why would the mandatory statute,
be unconstitutional if the goal is to
limit tray eliminate arbitrariness.
And of course,
some members of the court felt that
mandatory death pony was perfectly
appropriate.
Uh,
but the court was concerned about,
first of all,
the risk of arbitrariness,
uh,
justice Stevens and writes his opinion,
talks about,
uh,
jurors often would nullify,
would not return a verdict of guilty
if they felt the death plenty was not
appropriate.
Uh,
but I think what really is a critical
take home lesson of Woodson versus North
Carolina,
which struck down in the
North Carolina Statute,
uh,
is,
the failure to consider the individual
circumstances of the offender.
This is going to become one of the most
important principles in modern death
pony law that the jury cannot treat.
The person accused,
uh,
as a faceless mass of criminals.
The,
that this can't be defined just by
the crime you must take into account,
uh,
the diverse frailties of humankind.
Uh,
anything about the life and background
of the person that meditates in favor of
a sentence less than death.
And this is the basis upon which the
mandatory death pony statutes are struck
down cause four justices would
have uphold them and said,
you know,
these are states can decide,
uh,
what the jury can consider it if the
state wants to make it mandatory on the
crime.
There's no requirement of
individualized sentencing,
but the majority of the court,
uh,
the plurality that I described,
and Brennan and Marshall,
uh,
come together to hold a,
that there must be consideration
of individual circumstances,
uh,
in order to impose the death pony.
Um,
well what do we get out of these opinions?
Let's look at the critical opinions,
which is justice Stewart
Powell and Stevens A.
And look at how the court dealt with
some of these issues that we had in 1972
and Furman versus Georgia.
First of all,
the evolving standards of decency,
uh,
35 state legislatures,
have now adopted the death pony and many
juries have imposed it and this group
says,
and,
and the others who joined them,
Chief Justice Burger and that group,
uh,
it's clear that the death plenty does
not violate the evolving standards of
decency.
Because 35 legislature's wouldn't
have adopted it if it did.
So it tells us that society
accepts the death pony,
dignity,
uh,
dignity.
Uh,
these justices say relates to the
consideration of individual circumstances.
Brennan and Marshall would say
dignity means the death penalty is
unconstitutional,
but the majority,
or at least the plurality here,
holds that dignity,
says you've got to look into
the individual circumstances
of the person who's
facing the death colleague.
Uh,
they also talk about,
uh,
that it cannot be so without justification
that it results in the gratuitous
infliction,
uh,
of,
of suffering.
Uh,
and then they uphold it
based on the purposes.
Retribution.
Rimera Justice Marshall had said
previously that retribution was not even a
valid consideration.
We see in the 1976 cases that most
of the members of the court except
retribution,
a sentencing somebody to
punish them for what they did,
uh,
is a fair reason to have the death.
Polian if a state legislature
decides it wants it for that purpose,
it can have it.
The Terrance is a tricky question because
the studies on deterrence are all are
mixed.
I mean some,
uh,
find that,
the death penalty deters and
others most find that it does not.
Uh,
before,
uh,
in 1972,
justice Brennan and some of the
other members of court had said,
well,
unless the states can
show that it deters a,
they can't have the death pony.
In other words,
they put the burden of
proof on the states.
Well,
now the court changes that,
uh,
at least this plurality
of justice does and says,
ah,
it's up to the legislature to decide,
uh,
whether it deters.
And if a state legislature decides
that it wants to adopt the death point
because it believes that deters,
uh,
that's up to the legislature
and the challengers,
the challenging the death Tony would
have to show that it does not deter,
uh,
which again,
if the studies are all in conflict,
that's going to be and has been
pretty impossible to prove.
Um,
Brennan and Marshall,
different notion of dignity,
the intrinsic worth of people,
uh,
as human beings,
that,
uh,
Brennan says the punishment
must not be degrading,
as we talked about before,
Marshall must not be the total
denial of the wrongdoers,
dignity and worth,
uh,
this turns out to be a minority view,
because the majority says we look at
dignity only to look at the individual
circumstances of the people.
We don't think that
extinguishing human life,
uh,
is a,
a front and dignity in a way that
violates the eighth amendment to the
constitution in the way that justice,
uh,
Chief Justice Warren had
described in Troup versus Dallas.
Um,
retribution a here justice Stewart
repeats some of what he had said.
And Greg,
uh,
when people believe that the organized
society is not going to impose a
punishment on criminals,
uh,
that they deserve a,
then he says,
then you sow the seeds of a
vigilante justice lynch mob,
uh,
self help and so forth.
Uh,
and so he basically is saying,
we have to channel this,
uh,
passion,
this reaction,
this thirst for vengeance.
Uh,
that comes out of a terrible crime,
uh,
by allowing it to be done in the courts
as opposed to having people resort to
vigilante justice or Lynch law.
It shows how close we are in
time to the time of Lynch law,
uh,
and vigilante justice of the race riots
and the lynchings that had gone on,
uh,
earlier,
in the century,
uh,
and are not lingering met far behind.
Of course,
one can argue,
uh,
that basically the government ought to
be able to deal with a vigilante justice
and Lynch law doesn't necessarily have
to have the death pointing to do that.
And of course,
the number of states,
uh,
still 15 did not have the
death Pawnee at this time.
The other thing the court says
with the gardener retribution,
certain crimes themselves are so grievous,
uh,
that they,
such an affront to humanity.
The only adequate punishment is
going to be the sentence of death.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
the court finds that
for a murder at least,
which all these cases involved murders,
uh,
the five cases,
we're going to see later the court
looking at some non murder cases to decide
whether it's appropriate to
impose the death penalty.
But with these cases,
the court says some crimes
so grievous in the front,
uh,
to society,
that they can be punished
by the death penalty.
Um,
deterrence is to come back
to what I said earlier,
the studies have been inconclusive.
Uh,
the plurality says,
uh,
probably there's some people for whom a
deterrence works and there are probably
other people who are not deterred a,
but we're not going to get into that.
It's a complex issue.
Uh,
it's not for the court to sort out,
as I said earlier,
it's for the legislature.
And so we're going to
let the legislature's,
the state legislatures and Congress,
uh,
have hearings here,
the pros and cons of deterrence and
whether the death penalty deters and make
their own decision,
whether to adopt the death Polly.
So it pretty much takes
deterrence off the table.
Uh,
in the,
uh,
in decision the court was talking
a lot and members of the court,
we were talking a lot about is this
serving the purpose of deterrence and some
justice,
we're saying it's so
infrequently used and,
and uh,
it's so arbitrary that it doesn't deter,
but now the court is basically saying
we're going to leave to turns to the
legislatures.
Uh,
it's not for us to decide.
and so,
uh,
retribution is an acceptable
reason to have the death pony.
Deterrence is something we're
leaving up to the legislators.
So what's the answer?
What's the,
uh,
what do we come out of the 1976
cases with bifurcated trials?
Every state that has the death penalty,
uh,
has bifurcated trials.
One trial on guilt or innocence and
another on penalty narrow the class of
eligibles,
a narrow who can be sentenced to death.
That is provide what justice
white was looking for in 1972.
That principled reason why
some people get the death,
Tony and others do not.
And we saw the Georgia
did that by providing,
once the jury finds an
aggravating circumstance,
it has complete discretion,
uh,
Florida,
ways whether there's sufficient
mitigating circumstances that outweigh the
aggravating circumstances.
And finally,
Texas gives the jury three questions
and it answers those questions.
And as I said earlier,
if the question is answered yes,
then it means the death plenty is imposed.
If it's answered no to any
of the questions than the
death pony is not imposed.
Um,
three discretion of the jury must be
suitably directed and limited to minimize
the risk of arbitrary and
capricious sentencing.
In other words,
we've got to tell the jury how it's to
go about its job in a way that takes into
account the circumstances of the crime,
but also the circumstances
of the individual,
the offender and the jury
must be given guidance with,
these are jury instructions
we're talking about here,
clear and objective standards about
the fact of the crime and about the
defendant.
And so,
uh,
those are,
critical.
Now,
in addition to that,
uh,
we saw that,
automatic appeal was
provided for by Georgia,
had been provided in Florida.
Uh,
it's unclear whether it's
constitutionally required.
The court sort of talks about
it with approval in these cases.
Uh,
but it's never held that
automatic appeal is required.
And by automatic,
I mean,
even if the defendant doesn't
file a notice of appeal,
which is required in
other cases to appeal,
uh,
the,
the case if a DeCinces imposed that
case is going to be reviewed by a higher
court,
uh,
in every state that has the death penalty
and the federal government provide for
that.
Uh,
at the time these cases
were decided in 1976,
uh,
the thought was that
proportionality review,
like Georgia has a,
that is comparing the case in which the
defendant was sentenced to death with
other cases involving similar facts,
uh,
to decide whether the death
penalty was disproportionate.
That is,
is it excessive where there are
other people who got convicted,
a very similar crimes or
maybe more heinous crimes
who did not receive the death
tonic,
uh,
that was,
seen by some at that time as
constitutionally required.
But as we will see,
the court later holds that it's
not a constitutionally required.
And so most states abandoned
their proportionality review.
Once the Supreme Court decides that,
um,
Justice Powell says,
to sort of sum this up,
uh,
guidance is sufficient if the factors
channel the discretion of the jury by
requiring them to examine the factors
that argue in favor and against the death
public.
In other words,
the aggravating factors,
reasons to give the death Polly the
mitigating factors reasons not to give the
death Paul and the judges
to instruct the jury.
You've got to find one or more of these
aggravating factors that is in the
states that Florida and Georgia,
uh,
and then describes how
to consider mitigation.
Uh,
and theoretically that will,
uh,
put before the jury.
This is what the court
said couldn't be done.
And mcgautha mcgautha
said just a year earlier.
It's beyond human ability
to define before the fact.
What are the characteristics of the
crime and the offender that justify the
death point.
One year later under the eighth amendment,
the Supreme Court does exactly that.
Uh,
excuse me.
four years later,
the supreme court does exactly that.
Uh,
two other points which will leave with,
uh,
with regard to Greg versus Georgia and,
all the cases.
But this was mentioned in Greg.
First of all,
we're a life is at stake.
Uh,
the courts must be particularly
sensitive to see that every safeguard is
observed.
The idea,
at least in 1976,
was that if the death penalty is imposed,
then,
uh,
because death is different because of
the stakes involved because of the era
voke ability of the death point,
we going to make sure that
every safeguard is observed,
uh,
that uh,
will be abandoned,
uh,
as the years go by.
Uh,
but that was at least the notion in 1976.
And then secondly,
uh,
that accurate sentencing
information is indispensable.
In other words,
the jury has to have not
just the facts of the crime,
they're going to have that because the
law enforcement is going to investigate a
crime.
They're going to present all the details
that are available with regard to how
the crime was committed,
but also have to have the
information about the offender,
the circumstances of the offender.
And this is going to put a great deal of
responsibility on defense counsel as we
will talk about later in the course.
Uh,
the responsibility of defense counsel to
conduct the investigation into the life
and background,
uh,
of,
the defendant,
uh,
and uh,
put that evidence before the jury so that
it can give consideration not only to
the circumstances of the crime,
but the life and background
of the defendant and any
factors that are mitigating
factors that militate in favor
of a sentence less than death.
So once the dust clears a,
with these five decisions coming out,
we know that guided discretion
statutes are constitutional.
Uh,
Georgia,
Florida and Texas are going
to be allowed to go ahead.
Other states are going
to adopt a statutes.
Like there's probably
the model is Florida,
the weighing statute.
That's what the federal government has
in a number of other states have adopted
weighing statutes.
But there are also states that adopted
future dangerousness determinations,
uh,
and,
and other elements of these three cases.
Uh,
but basically this,
let the states know
this is what you can do,
a,
that's constitutional and you cannot
have a mandatory death penalty.
The court considered a number of cases
later on and involving mandatory death
plenty in certain circumstances
where the argument was made.
Well if you kill a person in prison after
you've been since the life in prison,
you could have a mandatory death when no,
not.
So basically the court has rejected every,
uh,
ever to justify a mandatory death points.
So juries have to have some discretion
in whether or not to impose the death
penalty.
They have to be instructed as to what
factors militate in favor of the death
penalty.
What factors militate against the death
Pollock and what will take up next a is
the death pony for certain crimes.
Uh,
whether the death penalty
can be imposed for,
uh,
the role of the offender and the crime
for particular crimes where there's not a
murderer involved.
Uh,
and then for particular people,
uh,
for children,
for intellectually disabled
people and other people.
Are there some people that under
the cruel and unusual clause,
the death police should really be off
limits and that's what we'll take them in
our next session.